singing on a stage before thousands of
employees alibaba's Jack Ma it's not
your average corporate chairman he
flunked his college entrance exam twice
he was English became an English teacher
and then left the classroom to ride the
internet wave as China's economy opened
up in the 90s
first starting China Yellow Pages
mantras waited 80 people to give him
$60,000 he then recruited 17 partners
and Alibaba was born and even though
he's just over five feet tall Jack mozz
larger-than-life personality has helped
Alibaba flow into the e-commerce Giants
it is today he sings and performs mass
weddings for employees during corporate
events he's a huge fan of kungfu and
even started a tai chi sport with actor
jet weeks he points Chinese philosophers
of meetings and Maz own wisdom has
helped grow his personal fortune to 22
billion dollars Jack Ma is now China's
richest man ahead of other Chinese tech
titans like $0.10 Ponemah and Baidu's
Robin Lee but for MA it's not just about
some money he told Charlie Rose that if
Alibaba cannot surpass Microsoft or
Walmart he'll regret it for the rest of
his life